on arrive à mi décembre où c'est notre
deuxième avis de sur le micron du 16
décembre
qui essaient de faire le point où on est
à sont là avec une transmission est
nettement plus élevé ça on le savait et
on commence un peu à savoir qui va être
moins gras donc comment seulement on est
simple on le perd la mi-décembre des
choses vont très vite dans cette télé ça
va évoluer dans cette peu dans cette
pathologie
est donc on a au cours des des jours qui
précède la sortie de notre avis une
série de dialogues comme je l'indiqué
selon les façons donc que j'ai indiquées
pour quelle était notre impression il ya
quelque chose de complètement nouveau
souvenez vous qu on est encore dans la
vague delta sont là vous êtes aussi au
camp mois maintenant
avec des hôpitaux qui sont les services
de réanimation qui commence déjà à être
lourdement chargé en particulier dans
certaines régions est la question posée
évidemment et ça va et où on va avec au
micron est ce qu'on va vers eux un à
micron 2022 on premier trimestre de
lille 1-2 qui va nous on est tous en mur
ou est-ce qu'au contraire on a quelque
chose de plus nuancé et nous prenons
parti
lors d'une discussion avec les autorités
en disant qu'on pense que ça va passer
au prix d'un certain nombre de mesures
lourdes mais qui ne seront pas des
mesures de restriction difficile comme
on les a vécus lors des premiers
confinement des couvre-feux et donc
parce que en raison de la gravité et
selon des modélisations sur lequel je
n'entrerai pas puisque vous écouter
demain matin
alors nous ferons tanner et
son collègue de l'institut pasteur et
qui vous expliquera en détail comment on
peut moduler en fonction la fois de la
gravité du du niveau de sévérité du
nombre de lits en réa comme on arrive à
construire quelque chose qui fait qu'on
peut penser à l'avant ce
que
contrairement à l'idée qu'on pouvait se
faire alors qu'on a des chiffres qui
sont cons des cimes voyez à l'époque que
vous l'avez rappelé autour de 200 milles
au près et on est monté à plus que ça
finalement
et bien qu'on va quand même passé sans
mesures de restriction majeure alors
pour revenir à la question précise que
vous me posez on a discuté du coup dont
on a commencé à discuter des différents
objets de deux mesures sanitaires qui
pourrait être qui pourrait être mis en
place il y avait déjà une discussion qui
tournait en fente ranimer le passage du
pass sanitaire au réseau vaccinale
depuis avant même l'arrivée de micro bic
a été accélérée entre guillemets par
parler au micro
voilà on a une réunion
[Musique]
le 17 décembre où on à la fois où il y
avait un grand m qui était notre vision
vis-à-vis de micron sur le premier
trimestre 2010 22 et puis une première
discussion etc et cette réunion était à
matignon
avec le premier ministre et un certain
nombre de
responsables sanitaires c'est vrai
qu'elle on a pu discuter aussi de la
fois où on allait avec au micron et où
nous allions éventuellement les pas mise
en place d'un pass vaccinale
je rappelle que le comité scientifique a
joué un rôle important
sur l'idée même du pass sanitaire 11
juin
2021 il ya eu toute une discussion à
l'époque sur fallait-il aller vers une
obligation vaccinale ou sur un pass
sanitaires et ne nous sommes mouillé en
l'écrivant on peut retrouver les écrits
sur l'idée même d'aller plutôt vers la
construction juridique 1 ont laissé des
l'éternité de l'employé d'avec eux et
avec les différentes instances grande
instance juridique en france d'aller
vers un pass le à l'edl et leur impact
sanitaire
sur le post vaccinales et choses ont été
plus rapides c'est à dire qu'en fait
nous nous étions dans au micron et donc
qu'elle allait être l'impact sanitaire
de au micro on est en même temps il y
avait la réflexion sur le pass vaccinale
donc on a discuté mais nous n'avons pas
écrit en tant que tel comme nous
l'avions écrit pour le pass le pass
sanitaires
et après quand on nous a demandé notre
avis avec ce décalage que vous évoquez
sur la date le conseil scientifique jugé
que compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire
que compte tenu de ce qu'on savait sur
l'efficacité des vaccins on pourra y
revenir si rouler et que de compte tenu
de cons se commencer à savoir sur la
sensibilité du variant au micron
vis-à-vis des vaccins il était
pleinement justifié de mettre en place
un pass vaccinale sur l'ensemble de ces
demandes des autorités de santé des
autorités sanitaires des politiques
puisque c'est cannes une décision
politique
sur l'ensemble de seulement bon à chaque
fois ans se voit larmes ce nous sommes
c'est deux malheureux médecins et
scientifiques et donc à chaque fois on
se dit mais mon dieu est ce qu'on n'est
pas là en train de on ne demande des
choses qu'ils sont eux la limite de
notre de notre savoir faire au service
et dans la loi puisque la loi oblige
entre guillemets les autorités
sanitaires à voir la vie dacoda conseil
scientifique
me dire que c'est ça ne brasse pas une
situation en tant que citoyen si la
réponse est oui et vous pouvez remarquer
que pour l'ensemble de nos positions à
chaque fois nous écrivons que cette
cette mise en place soient dupes hassani
terre soit de la question vous poser
autour du patio vaccinale elle est
justifiée par l'état de la pandémie et
de l'épidémie sanitaire n'est que celle
ci pourrait évoluer dans le temps et
qu'il faudra savoir évoluer dans le
temps également pour éventuellement
prendre des décisions de revenir en tri
mais en arrière ou de savoir évoluer sur
les conditions du pass vaccinale et
c'est évidemment notre position c'est
ces aides ma position est également 2
savoir quand est-ce qu'il faudra évoluer
sur en fonction de l'épidémie de
l'épidémie dernier point après je vous
laisse me poser mes questions le conseil
scientifique a même été plus loin
et au mois d'octobre sur un avis que
j'ai ici mais que voilà vous avez
peut-être pas retenu dans le temps
questionnement d'aujourd'hui nous avons
nous avions souhaité aller plus loin en
terme de
deux je dirais 2-2 de simplifier entre
guillemets
la situation de la situation saine 2-2
des mesures d'ensemble de restriction
servi du du 5 octobre 2021 vous allez
voir que je me donne des coups pour me
faire battre mais c'est la vie il sait
le titre s'appelle une situation apaisée
quand et comment alléger
le 5 octobre 2021 le conseil
scientifique est considéré par beaucoup
de gens comme étant extrêmement dur
sanitaire bon et c'est se poser la
question une situation apaisée quand et
comment les jets
nous recommandions quand même après un
lourd et difficile débat au sein du
conseil scientifique
il était peut-être urgent d'attendre
avant d'alléger
c'est ce qui était un peu comprennent
touahri avec matip
et depuis et depuis
nous avons eu le deuxième pic la
quatrième vague leanne ltan sur des
deltas un premier pic au mois de juin
somme toute pas les chambres à deuxième
pic beaucoup plus difficile à gérer à
partir justement à peu près de sa de la
fin octobre du mois de novembre jusqu'à
la mi-décembre et l'arrivée de micron
donc ça veut dire qu'il est c'est c'est
vraiment difficile un cessez le monde
ici les
mêmes quand on a le souhait fondamental
que
que nous avons au niveau du cs de se
dire que les mesures doivent être
proportionnées en fonction de l'état de
l'acquis de de la pandémie il est
extrêmement difficile d'anticiper
alors pour terminer je pense que vous me
posez la légation après avoir goûté tout
ça où on en est là maintenant au bâton
et sur quels critères pour et ont
éventuellement alléger le pass vaccinale
où en est on
on donnait à peu près où on avait dit
qu'on arriverait c'est-à-dire il ya eu
une explosion des décontaminations
pourvu qu'on avait parlé je vous en
avais part dès début janvier quand
j'étais venu ou dans une autre salle et
il ya cette se sait je dis moi dans
l'histoire de la pandémie c'est cet
autre chose c'est une autre histoire
vient de se passer avec au micro un
c'est toujours le sens comme de bien sûr
mais on est dans autre chose on est dans
un virus qui est beaucoup plus
contagieux métiers moins sévère et donc
cesser enfin on est dans une avec une
mise à niveau de vaccination qui
accueille qui n'a strictement rien à
voir avec les vagues précédentes et les
variantes précédente donc on est dans
une autre histoire et il ya donc cette
dissociation majeure entre le nombre de
contaminations par amine plusieurs
centaines de milles vous imaginez et
puis le l'impact sur le système de soins
il reste en relativement bon un haut
niveau avec autour de
hospitalisation en soins intensifs
ils sont liés
maintenant uniquement au micro c'est
fini pour delta dont qui sont bien liés
au micro-ondes ont tireront on peut être
micron est arrivé en soins intensifs
entre guillemets et avec un nombre de
finalisations qui est élevé le nombre de
subtilisation est pratiquement en niveau
où nous étions nombreux fidélisation la
première vague
je dis bien je répète mes mots le nombre
d'hospitalisations classique est en ce
moment pratiquement au niveau du nom du
nombre d'hospitalisations qu'elle nous
étions lors de la première balle par
contre le nombre d'hospitalisations en
soins intensifs et en réanimation il est
plus faible on est donc autour de 3800
alors que nous sommes montés ou savait
presque à 7000 l'or lors de la première
vague
les choses ont l'air de se stabiliser
mais un haut niveau c'est qu'on va avoir
un impact sur le système de soins qui va
durer jusqu'à début mars mi mars
le pic est probablement passé la semaine
dernière en ile de france il reste des
régions de france ils sont encore très
durement touchées où le pic des bahamas
et c'est le cas en particulier vend en
occitanie et ans et en est une nouvelle
aquitaine où il s'enrichit encore
extrêmement difficile
et donc on est un très haut niveau pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée aussi
puisqu'on va se poser légitimement la
question et vous pouvez vous poser
légitimement la question
pourquoi la france ne fait pas ce qui se
fait en angleterre en uk et au danemark
alors si on regarde les chiffres
du de uk et du danemark ils sont à des
niveaux
hospitalisation en soins intensifs
par rapport à ce qu'ils ont vécu lors de
la première vague et n'ont strictement
rien à voir avec notre niveau nous
d'occupation des soins intensifs
cccc des chiffres qui sont qui sont
beaucoup plus bas
leur niveau d'occupation
nombre de lits a évidemment population
après
prise en compte est à un niveau beaucoup
plus bas que le niveau auquel nous
sommes en france 1 c'est dire qu'ils
prennent des mesures
pour lever les mesures alors même que
leur système de soin est beaucoup moins
impactées en termes de lits de soins
intensifs
qu'est ce que nous avons en france donc
pour être nous ne sommes pas encore
arrivés au bout de la vague on est dans
la vague et les médecins et les médecins
et les réanimateurs sentent bien que ça
va passer mais qui sont encore les mains
dans le cambouis et de façon difficile
et en particulier dans certaines régions
et jusqu'à jusqu'à peu la mi mars
donc les marqueurs les marqueurs sont
finalement l'impact sur le système de
soins
ce ne sont plus le chiffre de
contamination qui ne veut plus haut
depuis qu'il ne veut plus dire grand
chose puisque ce sont des deux le site
de contamination qui va pas dire grand
chose puisque ce sont des contaminations
avec un invariant finalement qui était
que sévère ou pas trop sévère en tout
cas et c'est ce qui compte c'est
l'échelle sociale de son don quand on a
des marqueurs qui sont assez tardif mais
qui pour contre des décisions tu dirais
qu'ils pourraient être potentiellement
des décisions de lever à la limite
d'avoir des marqueurs tardif au
contraire c'est un marqueur solide on
n'est pas dans dans l'autre dans l'autre
point d'avoir des marqueurs très précoce
on pourra prendre des décisions en
anticipation là on est dans des
décisions qui pourraient être celles de
lever bon bah il faudra s'appuyer
essentiellement sur l'impact sur le
système de soins et je ne vais pas plus
loin parce qu'après ça sera des
décisions qui sont à prendre pour les
autorités sanitaires ceci évidemment si
nous n'avons pas de nouveaux variants et
si le sou variant de 2 microns à b2 et
bien tu vas être qui va paraître très
très vite la ville cambrai en france
tient ce qui compense c'est à dire qu'il
est encore plus transmissible ce qui est
logique puisqu'il prend il domine sur le
sur le premier varié en micron pour
dominer il faut être plus transmissible
mais on pense qu'il est pas plus et là
[Musique]